you know the problem is they couldn't
find any mean reviews of you but they
had many me
you're gonna read what critics had to
say about your films which film they're
talking about it sounds god-awful and
title and concept but which in execution
is a busy delight warning the sight of
middle-aged errs bonking may cause team
tremors I wish there was not to me
company so we had to cover it it was
embarrassing
I don't know Bridget Jones's baby yes oh
great
as it turns out 93 main characters is
too many was I in one of those movies
like you know like where there's lots
and lots of fun characters I don't know
it's a sequel I was in a sequel you are
apparently Night at the Museum thank you
I was a docent in white letters I walked
into the scene and I was like everyone
come this way and then I walked over in
it I'm the face of that movie yeah yeah
suddenly you are okay
Blanc is like being loved in slow motion
by beautiful people it's going through
devotion you didn't even need that clue
you know what I really like the one went
Hugh Grant is singing that pointer
sister saw oh yeah absolutely
um every generation gets the neverending
story it deserves this one may very well
be ours that's very nice and I think
that is a wrinkle in time Emma Thompson
is totally wasted in this movie meaning
that I'm absolutely all filled all the
way through I wish it was drunk
but I think it's that you were you were
not used well to dearer abilities so I
don't know what is his it's jr. did you
have fun working with Arnold
Schwarzenegger yes on tears he was very
respectful and then he weighed me he
said can I go I said sure and he picked
me up and said hundred thirty-two pounds
I said it's pretty accurate
actually these women are just great fun
to hang with and I'd happily sit still
for a slew of sequels I think that seems
like oceans 8 yeah absolutely
I'd enjoy listening to Emma Thompson
even if she was reading me my list of
offenses against the crown I simply
don't know that's just a nice thing that
someone said about me yes beautiful
creatures okay okay yet another
compliment Thomson this is okay it's so
good you'll think you hallucinate it is
I don't know if this is the end this is
the end okay I hate to be a broken
record here but I walked into a party at
their house and then I was instantly
killed and fell into a ditch
so anyway blank that this movie is a
composite of Margaret Hamilton mrs. Pig
a wiggle and the grunting Carl from
Slingblade same to me Cappy ho-ho hell
no ho ho hell no that's both rude and a
parody of what Santa would say was it
the night before it was context clues do
you note that actually we can't remember
what movies we've been in I've got my
name on the side of a bus the other day
and I thought I might in that I need
your pushiness and lack of boundaries
you left me no I didn't say that I know
I mean not in those words but you know I
didn't say it in any of those words
[Music]
you